Trascrizione: Silvia Rossi
Revisore: Giorgia Zanfardin
Questa è una di quelle storie
dove il punto di partenza
e il punto di arrivo
è sempre lo stesso,
ma posso assicurarvi
che non sono stato fermo.
Tutto cominciò nel 2013
quando veramente decisi di partire.
Torino mi stava un po' stretta,
stavo facendo le stesse cose
da troppo tempo,
avevo bisogno di fare nuove esperienze
e mi stavo un po' avvitando su me stesso.
La spinta fu
cercare di raggiungere una persona cara.
Questa persona cara si trovava in Nepal.
Da musicista avevo voglia,
quasi il bisogno
di unire l'esperienza del viaggio
alla mia grande passione.
Vi sembrerà strano ma, banalmente,
una notte digitai su Google
"Katmandu" e "jazz" e...
wow!
Katmandu Jazz Conservatory,
il conservatorio di Katmandu.
Scrissi immediatamente.
Mi risposero altrettanto immediatamente,
dopo circa una settimana.
Mi offrirono quattro mesi di contratto.
Si sa, il Nepal non è
una di quelle nazione ricche,
e quindi il contratto
non prevedeva, purtroppo,
la copertura delle spese
dei viaggi internazionali dall'Italia.
Così decisi di scrivere all'Istituto
di Cultura Italiano più vicino,
a Nuova Dehli, spiegandogli la situazione.
Beh, con mia grande sorpresa,
e senza contatti diretti,
mi offrirono dei concerti in India,
con i quali avrei potuto
coprire le spese di viaggio
e godere di un fondo
per vivere al meglio
l'esperienza nepalese.
Sono partito,
i concerti sono andati bene,
i contatti sono aumentati,
la ruota ha cominciato a girare:
sono stati tre anni magnifici di viaggio.
Ed ecco un piccolo assaggio.
(Musica)
L'esperienza da sassofonista globetrotter
mi ha cambiato radicalmente la vita.
Ho visto realtà in crescita:
la Cina, l'India, l'Australia,
dove l'italianità
è un valore aggiunto, di default,
che ho cercato di usare al meglio.
Ho anche ricevuto
ottime proposte di lavoro, ben retribuite,
da insegnante o da performer,
ma sono tornato.
Ho deciso di tornare.
Dopo anni passati ad assorbire
suoni, culture, colori,
ho sentito la necessità
di stare in un posto che fosse casa,
dove poter buttar fuori,
attraverso la musica,
tutto quello che avevo vissuto.
Charlie Parker, grande sassofonista,
disse:
"La musica è la tua esperienza,
i tuoi pensieri e la tua saggezza.
Se non vivi,
la musica non verrà mai
fuori dal tuo strumento."
Beh, nel mio caso la storia
di sassofonista viaggiatore
verrà raccontata
nel mio terzo album da solista
che è attualmente in produzione.
Un album che avrà atmosfere elettroniche,
improvvisazioni
e contaminazioni culturali.
Collaborerò con artisti locali
e artisti incontrati all'estero:
un percussionista senegalese,
la rapper cinese,
il cantante di musica classica indiano.
Torino è casa
e questo è il miglior posto per farlo.
Torino ha grandi potenzialità,
sta diventando sempre più
città internazionale.
Ci sono artisti di ottimo livello
con cui collaborare
e con cui confrontarsi.
C'è anche il rovescio della medaglia.
C'è da dire che solo in città,
nel mio piccolo,
so che ci sono venti, più o meno,
sassofonisti bravissimi, professionisti.
Proprio per questo
penso sia necessario lavorare
non tanto sull'essere più bravi
tecnicamente degli altri,
ma sulla propria unicità,
sulla propria autenticità.
Bisogna scavare dentro sé stessi
per sentire la propria voce
e per scoprire il proprio suono.
Ormai la bellezza del mix delle culture
sta diventando un must dei miei progetti.
Oltre al disco solista,
ho una band con cui amo suonare
formata da tre musicisti senegalesi
e due musicisti italiani,
tutti residenti a Torino.
La band si chiama Khora Beat
- Khora con l'acca -
e la khora è un'arpa tradizionale
dell'Africa occidentale.
Mi piace condividere
l'esperienza di sassofonista viaggiatore
e spiegare come sono riuscito a suonare in
festival, ambasciate, istituti di cultura
a coloro che hanno voglia
di buttarsi
come ho fatto io,
senza management,
senza agenzie di organizzazione eventi,
solo con le mie forze.
Molti mi chiedono dei piccoli,
ma importanti consigli
su cose che ho imparato sul campo.
Beh, quello che posso dire è che
viaggiare da solo
con uno strumento in spalla,
con la propria passione,
per mesi,
in paesi così diversi dal nostro
richiede coraggio,
richiede capacità organizzativa
e capacità improvvisativa.
Risolvere i problemi e le necessità
in tempi rapidi, cercare le scintille...
Sicuramente un'esperienza
che ti fa crescere come persona.
Torino è casa mia, è la mia base,
ma sopratutto per un mestiere come il mio
è necessario sapersi muovere,
saper partire, saper tornare,
saper rimanere, aspettare,
saper partire e tornare ancora.
Sì, dalla mia esperienza posso dire
che il posto che stavo cercando
è dentro di me e dentro il mio strumento.
Il brano che voglio suonarvi
è un brano composto tre anni fa,
prima della partenza per il Nepal.
Un brano che poi
mi ha portato molta fortuna,
con cui ho aperto i principali concerti
di tutti i tour.
Il brano si chiama "Chromatic Moon"
ed è un grande onore per me
potervelo suonare oggi.
Grazie e buon ascolto.
(Applausi)
(Musica)